transistors in the chips on our phones
and N PCS are now virus sized you need
bigger and bigger machines and bigger
and bigger and more complex Supply
chains so when the chip industry was
founded companies would do everything
themselves they'd make their own
production machines they'd refine their
own chemicals they produce their own
silicon Wafers they try to do it all
whereas today every step is so
mind-bogglingly complex and the level of
specificity and purification and
precision is so high that there's not a
single company that can do anything on
their own the number of firms the number
of countries involved in making a chip
inside your smartphone now measures
vastly larger than it would have in the
past and just the machines themselves
take a Cutting Edge lithography machine
they require multiple airplanes to move
because they're so large and then the
next Generation lithography machine that
will make even smaller circuitry will be
substantially larger because to make
smaller and smaller devices you need
bigger and bigger machines